what makes you different is what makes
you spider-man
my name is Peter Parker I'm pretty sure
you know the rest
I saved the city fell in love then I
saved the city again and again and again
look I'm a comic book
serial to get a Christmas album and it's
soso popsicle but this isn't about me
not anymore
spider-man swings in once the day's zip
zap zop in his little mask and answers
to no one I love you mines
[Music]
dad are you serious I wanted here dad I
love you got the car my name is Miles
Morales
one and only spider-man at least that's
what I thought you'll be here for
supercollider you got all of this you're
like me that's impossible
alright kid listen up this part is your
universe
soggy it's weird it's gross and this
delicious normal fry is my universe so
you want to learn to be spider-man teen
teacher yes I can
time to swing good doing it double tap
to release and clip it out again grip
and release your natural lip
[Music]
hey guys who are you I'm Gwen Stacy I'm
from another another dimension
how many more spider people are there
hey fellas this could literally not get
any weirder it can get weird okay we
need to get back to our universes soon
Brooklyn is going to collapse my family
lives in Brooklyn whoa this was better
yes
[Music]
it's mine if I don't destroy the karate
none of us will have a home to go home
to remember what makes you different
that's all
is what makes you spider-man
officer I love you wait do animals talk
in this dimension cuz I don't want to
freak him out
[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody its charlie we got a new
spider-man into the spider-verse trailer
to break down with more versions of
spider-man from the multiverse and a
whole bunch of Easter eggs they totally
canonized the Tobey Maguire spider-man
movies at the beginning of this when he
was narrating his backstory we're still
doing that spider-man ps4 game giveaway
all you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a spider-man
related comment on the video freaking
out about all the spider-man related
stuff that's happening right now like
seriously my venom non-spoilery review
is gonna post tonight this is prime
spider-man territory because this movie
is coming in December then we have two
more spider-man related movies coming
next year between Avengers 4 in
spider-man far from home so we finally
get some footage of Wilson Fisk who
seems like it's gonna be the real big
bad of this movie because he creates the
super collider that weakens the bonds of
the multiverse that allow all the other
Spider Men to cross over into miles as
Ultimates dimension so the way they
explain it each one of these spider
people in the movie is from a different
dimension but the way miles his father
talks he talks about spider-man there
may have been an earlier version of
Peter Parker spider-man on miles as
Earth before this version of Peter comes
from the 6-1-6 universe the Jake Johnson
Peter that you hear talking during the
trailer it sounded like he came from the
6-1-6 universe but actually you know
technically if they're gonna canonize
the Tobey Maguire films you could say
that he came from that universe but as
they explained that the whole plot of
the movie is them trying to stop the
super collider from collapsing Brooklyn
and probably the rest of miles as
Ultimates world into the multiverse like
it literally just collapse in on itself
we get to hear all the other versions of
spider-man
speak in this so confirmed Peter Parker
from another universe played by Jake
Johnson spider-gwen from another
universe played by Hailee Steinfeld who
we actually just saw during the
Transformers bumblebee trailer
spider-man noir played by Nicolas Cage
it was cool to finally get to hear him
speak this little girl doing the kawaii
anime pose is actually penny Parker
fighting her mech if you didn't read it
there was this Gerard Way story where he
did this neon genesis evangelion
spider-man story she's from another
universe where they have mechs like they
do during neon genesis evangelion that
are all based on spider qualities so she
has the powers of spider-man but she
also
pilots this mech she's fighting it in
the trailer people thought that it was a
spider Slayer but she can climb in it
and pilot it just like they do during
Evangelion then of course we finally get
to hear John mulaney's speak as
spider-ham oh it can get weirder as he
walks up I love that funny moment from
the trailer to where they're peeping on
miles his friend and he's reading the
comic book which is a reference to the
what-if title like what if there were
other versions of Spider Man then he
looks up and sees them all on the
ceiling and John Mulaney is spider-ham
says do animals talk in this dimension I
don't want to freak him out
so there are a lot of meta references to
the spider verse within the movie beyond
them just actually having multiple
versions of Peter if you guys didn't
know this is Phil Lord and Chris Miller
that did the lego movie so there's a
whole bunch of meta references from that
expect the same treatment for the spider
verse so there's references to like the
Tobey Maguire films to the spider-man
comics like when Peter is narrating his
backstory there's this picture of the
chameleon title that's actually amazing
spider-man number 186 but they changed
the title to say true life of spider-man
instead of amazing spider-man so they
changed a couple minor things but like
Toby's movies you see them do the upside
down kiss from the first spider-man
movie there's a whole bunch of Doctor
Octopus scenes where he's stopping the
train from spider-man to the scene where
he throws the car through the restaurant
window while he's talking to Mary Jane
there's a big montage where he's
actually fighting all the villains from
the spider-man movies I think this green
hand is from the lizard so they might
also be canonizing the Andrew Garfield
movies in this too the serial is
probably a reference to the serial that
they released as a tie-in product with
the 1990s animated series way back of
course during the 90s I never actually
ate that I'm sure it just tasted like
normal cereal one of the funnier ones
too is the popsicle picture obviously
that's a real thing that's from real
life
somebody took that that's working on the
movie in real life then just copy pasted
it into the trailer no idea where this
spider lair is but I'm guessing that it
belongs to the Jake Johnson Peter Parker
just because he's been spider-man for so
long and you see all the different
versions of his suits in the background
if you look real hard you can even spot
the advance suit from the spider-man ps4
game in the background here so they
canonized the events of that game to
this movie now that is now
part of the spider-verse when he gets
all worried about Brooklyn talking about
how he has to save his family you
actually get a shot of the Prowler his
uncle without his costume on there's a
big fight scene with scorpion and
tombstone in someone's house here I love
this shot a penny Parker in the
background - just watching miles get his
ass handed to him like you know he's
doing fine he doesn't need my help I'll
just wait a second another shot of
ultimate Goblin no idea how big Norman
Osborn is - the plot of this movie or if
they dispatch him but I'm guessing just
because they're setting up so much
spider-verse crossover that they'll just
continue that into whatever the sequel
ends up doing so a couple big plot lines
Myles becoming the main version of
spider-man on his earth and then them
weakening the bonds of the multiverse so
that all these versions of spider-man
can crossover with each other what they
might do by the end of the movie is
defeat Wilson Fisk and fix this super
collider situation so that Brooklyn
doesn't collapse in on itself but leave
a way for them to cross into other
universes so that they can continue to
cross over in future sequels so there
any Big East race that you guys spotted
that I didn't mention in the video just
write them in the comments below there's
so much stuff going on during this and
just a reminder that it's coming out the
week of Christmas that's also the same
week that the Aquaman movie is coming
out so there's a whole bunch of movie
stuff happening in December the giveaway
for the game will be going all week long
but I'll name a new winner when I post
my non-spoilery venom review later
tonight while you wait for everything
click here for that new spider-man far
from home of Mysterio scene with him in
the black costume and click here for
that brand new venom trailer thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]